- Hi, I'm Shannon from Khan Academy,
and I wanna show you how to make the most
of your learning time.
First, make sure you're logged into
your Khan Academy account
by checking for your name
in the upper right-hand corner.
If you are not logged in,
you won't be able to view your assignments
and any progress you make
won't be counted towards your classes.
Now, on the left-hand side,
you should see your classes
where your teacher has
given you a mastery goal
or an assignment to work on.
Click on the tab that says assignments
to view assignments from your teacher.
On the assignments tab,
you can see all your upcoming
and past due assignments.
Assignments with the nearest due date
will appear at the very top of the list.
Now that you're ready to go,
let's talk about the
top five things to know
about assignments on Khan Academy.
Number one, types of assignments.
There are two main types of assignments
you can receive on Khan Academy.
The first type is practice,
noted with the star symbol.
Practice can be an exercise,
quiz, or unit test.
When you complete
practice on Khan Academy,
you receive instant
feedback after every answer.
Answer all questions to
complete the assignment
and receive a score.
The second type is instruction,
noted with the play symbol
and the paper symbol.
Instruction can be in the
form of videos or articles.
Videos and articles can
help you learn new skills
or review things you learned in class.
All videos have subtitles,
so you can easily follow along.
Number two, if you're stuck, take a hint.
It's normal to feel stuck when
you're learning new skills,
but the important thing
is you don't give up.
Take a hint to get
step-by-step instructions
to the specific question
you're working on.
We recommend that you
write these hints down
so you can reference them later.
You can also try watching a video
or reading an article on this skill,
even if it hasn't been assigned to you.
You'll find the videos and articles
related to each skill you're practicing
by clicking this stuck or get help link.
Once you've done that,
you're ready to retry
the practice exercise.
And if you're still stuck,
reach out to a classmate,
teacher, or a family member
for support.
Number three, be patient and persistent.
Not happy with the score you received
on a practice exercise?
Trust me, we've all been there.
But remember, on Khan Academy,
you can always retry assignments
until you earn a that you are proud of.
Click try again to retry.
You can also return to assignments
where the due dates have passed
to try to improve your score.
Struggles and mistakes are
what helps your brain grow,
so keep persisting.
Number four, check your progress.
On the left-hand side,
select progress under my account.
From here, you can review
all of the activity on Khan Academy.
This includes exercises you
completed, videos you watched,
or articles you read.
Depending on your learning goals,
you may wanna filter
to view a certain type
of content or activity.
And for each practice you completed,
you can view your current mastery level,
the number of questions
you answered correctly,
and how much time you
spent on the activity.
It's helpful to regularly
check your progress,
so you know if you're on
track to meet your goals.
Number five, make Khan Academy your own.
And finally, adjust Khan Academy
to work for your unique learning style.
You can slow down, speed
up, or rewind the videos
when you need to.
You can learn in the language
you're most comfortable with.
Khan Academy is available
in over 50 languages
and you can easily
switch between languages
in your settings.
And if you prefer,
you can complete
assignments on a smartphone.
Just download the Khan
Academy app on Android or iOS.
And remember, you have
the potential to succeed.
Keep trying, keep making mistakes,
and keep asking for help when you need it.
There is no limit to what you can learn.